but first haiti's prime minister has
sacked the chief prosecutor after he
asked the judge to charge the premier as
a suspect in the murder of presidents
juvenile murice the chief prosecutor had
also asked immigration agents to bar
arie along re from leaving the country
president moise was assassinated in july
and court documents say the prime
minister was called twice
in the errors after his death by one of
the main
suspects well michael diebert is an
author and journalist who's covered
haiti for almost 25 years his latest
book is called haiti will not perish he
joins us now from philadelphia this is a
rather extraordinary story and a rather
extraordinary
turn of events with the prime minister
himself now implicated in this what
exactly is going on in haiti
yes it's an extremely convoluted state
of affairs i mean as you mentioned the
was murdered uh now a little over two
months ago and it was quite clear from
the circumstances of his death that
certainly his inner security was
compromised he was left essentially to
be assassinated by by allegedly by these
uh foreign mercenaries and what's been
swirling around or two things
essentially who in his inner circle uh
security and political was involved in
his murder and who the intellectual and
financial authors uh were of it and so
this latest development whereby the uh
chief prosecutor was essentially calling
for the sitting prime minister to be
indicted for his alleged role in the
murder and the prime minister sacking
that uh that prosecutor has just added
to the fuhrer and the tumult in haiti
okay well it's also added to the
confusion somewhat has it not i mean if
the the the prosecutor has now been
sacked uh does this not uh cast even
more doubt on the prime minister himself
and
and where does this leave the prime
minister i mean does the order to
uh
prevent the prime minister from leaving
the current does that still stand now
that the prosecutor has been sacked
well i think one one
important that the the prime minister
himself is ruling if it can be called
with extremely i guess you might say
questionable legitimacy i mean he was he
was named by a president many had
accused of staying over overstaying his
his term in office and had not in fact
been officially invested in that in that
position before joe and elmoy was killed
uh so the the question of the legitimacy
of the government i i think is really up
in the air right now for a lot of people
in haiti and and what about the the
investigation overall i mean do you
think haiti will ever find out
uh who killed juvenile movies
i think there's a lot of doubt among
people in haiti in terms of whether this
this investigation will be allowed to
run its course i mean most of the people
who have been arrested so far i don't
think anyone seriously thinks that they
were the the real money men were the
real intellectual authors of this crime
and unfortunately haiti has this very
long history of spectacular political
assassinations not necessarily leading
up to the presidency but with a lot of
other people that have never really come
to uh
satisfactory conclusion
in terms of investigation i think a lot
of people might want to see
you know some kind of uh maybe
international body investigate this
crime
okay well it's great to get your
thoughts and analysis thank you so much
as author and journalist michael deibert
joining us from philadelphia
thank you